Quick video there that stainless steel
two thousand and nineteen in the LT version.
Guys,
let's start with the main engine.
Two point zero tube,
two hundred and sixty-two horses,
thirty-seven kilos,
torque forcing,
one zero to one hundred in the seven point range,
six seconds and a nine-speed automatic lock,
zero wheel,
with tire two,
two,
five wide by sixty height,
four hundred and sixty-eight liter trunk,
a very nice space.
There's one more,
a trapdoor down here.
Interesting point, รณ.
Her escape,
he's a real double,
isn't he?
Those decoration leaks.
Her inner structure,
very good people,
flat floor And the seat back here,
it has an adjustment here on the backrest
also for the passengers in the back seat.
It also has electronic bank adjustments.
Her central inconsole here.
He's really nice,
with that very wide arm.
In this version,
it does not have a panoramic roof like in the Premier version
AND in the Premier version it will also have all-wheel drive,
while in the LT it is only front-wheel drive.